Now, let's move on, to rendering performance. Your
goal for rendering, for scrolling and animations, particularly, should
be smooth, gent free rendering. If your app,
is jumping around, as the user scrolls, or an
animation is periodically freezing, or, running at less
than a fast consistent frame rate, then your users
will be unhappy, with the experience. On desktop, we
always, tell you, the magic number is 16 milliseconds.
That's a single frame, when you're running at 60 frames a second, which
is the usual frame rate of the monitor. That's not always true and actually,
it's not even that you need to consistently hit 60 frames a second. It's
far more important, to have a consistent frame rate, than a high frame rate.